I am pleased to present the Civil silver
medal award to documentary in
documentary filmmaking to Maria Royale
Marva cancion I want them to start by
apologizing i went to apologize to my
family for exposing the story so much i
wouldn't expect to get so much attention
and but i want to I I think that it's
important to break break some silences
and I want to thank them for letting me
do it especially my grandma my mom I
want to thank to everybody that make
this possible the film especially
romanza and more especially and done
without whom this would never have been
possible and all my colleagues at the
City College of New York that gave me so
much feedback and so much criticism on
the time and my teachers and I have
something okay so I forget something
well and I think this is a way this is
going to be a lot of fuel for my new
project laughs organ Anna and I want to
thank of course the Academy for this
great days it's been pretty awesome how
warm they took us inside the family and
it's been really great to meet such a
wonderful people and thank you very much